INCLUDING THE BREAKING NEWS
CHRIS GAVE US.
THIS IS "DON LEMON TONIGHT."
PRESIDENT BIDEN AHEAD OF HIS
FIRST SPEECH SINCE TAKING
OFFICE.
THE PRESIDENT THAT RAN ON
BIPARTISANSHIP NOW FACES WHAT
YOU'D HAVE TO CALL OPEN WAR FAIR
BETWEEN MEMBERS OF HIS OWN
PARTY.
AND IT THREATENS TO DERAIL HIS
AGENDA.
SO-CALLED MODERATES AND
PROGRESSIVES BATTLING OVER
SIGNATURE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
AND ALEXANDRIA CASIO-CORTEZ
SAYS SHE'S A NO ON THE
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT PASSED THE
SENATE IF THE LARGER DEMOCRAT
ONLY BILL HASN'T PASSED BY NEXT
WEEK.
JOE MANSION DIGGING IN HEELS
CALLING ON DEMOCRATS TO SLOW
THEIR ROLE ON A BILL HE THINKS
HAS TOO HIGH A PRICE TAG.
>> SEPTEMBER 27th IS COMING UP
NEXT WEEK.
IS IT POSSIBLE THIS BILL COULD
PASS BY THEN?
>> I SAID THIS BEFORE.
I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT I FEEL ON
THAT.
WHATEVER YOU DO, GET IT RIGHT.
IF THERE IS NOT ENOUGH CLARITY,
THEN YOU NEED TO GET CLARITY.
>> YOU WANT TO DELAY TO NEXT
YEAR, RIGHT?
>> NO, YOU KNOW WHAT I SAID.
I SAID LET'S WAIT AND SEE
WHATEVER YOU NEED.
I'LL HAVE A GOOD IDEA.
>> OPEN WARFARE, RIGHT?
AYANNA PRESSLEY WAS BLUNT LAST
WEEK WHEN SHE TOLD ME WHO SHE
THINKS THE REAL OBSTRUCTIONESTS
ARE IN THIS.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO MANSION AND
CINEMA, LET THE RECORD REFLECT
WHO THE REAL OBSTRUCTIONESTS
ARE.
PROGRESSIVES ARE OFTEN MALIGNED
AND VILIFIED FOR, YOU KNOW,
SITTING AT THE -- FOR OUR
ADVANCING, SEEKING TO ADVANCE
BOTH PROGRESSIVE POLICIES WHICH
ARE THE PEOPLE'S POLICIES, WHICH
ARE IN FACT THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA.
>> AND THEN THERE IS OF COURSE
THIS BATTLE AGAINST COVID.
PFIZER ANNOUNCING THE NEWS
PARENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
BEEN WAITING FOR, SAYING ITS
VACCINE IS SAFE AND AGAIN RATED
WHAT THEY'RE CALLING A ROBUST
ANTIBODY RESPONSE IN CHILDREN
AGES 5 TO 11.
THE NEWS COULDN'T COME AT A
BETTER TIME WITH KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL AND THE CASES ON THE RISE
ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS SAYS THERE WERE
NEARLY 226,000 NEW CASES AMONG
KIDS OVER THE PAST WEEK.
THE SECOND HIGHEST TOTAL DURING
THE PANDEMIC.
A TENT HAS GONE UP, LOOK AT
THIS, OUTSIDE OF CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OF PITTSBURGH WHERE THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN COMING TO THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT IS BEING
CALLED HISTORIC.
NOW PARENTS ARE COUPLE COUPLING
COUNTING THE DAYS THEIR CHILDREN
CAN GET VACCINATED, MAYBE BY
HALLOWEEN BUT SEEING SO MANY
DYING EVERY DAY.
MORE THAN 675,000 PEOPLE HAVE
DIED OF COVID MORE THAN THE 1918
FLU PANDEMIC.
WE HAVE TWO WEAPONS, VACCINES
AND MASKS.
VACCINES AND MASKS.
SO IT'S NO TIME FOR LEADERS WHO
SHOULD KNOW BETTER WHO DO KNOW
BETTER TO BE ALL, YOU KNOW, DO
AS I SAY, NOT AS I DO.
SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON BREED
SCOLDING THE FUN POLICE, OKAY?
THAT'S AFTER SHE WAS CAUGHT ON
CAMERA DANCING AND SINGING ALONG
AT A BLACK CAT NIGHTCLUB, NO
MASK AND WITHOUT A DRINK OR FOOD
IN SIGHT.
THE CITY'S INDOOR MASK MANDATE
SAYS MASKS CAN BE TAKEN OFF
QUOTE WHILE ACTIVELY EATING OR
DRINKING.
BUT THE MAYOR IS DEFENDING
HERSELF.
>> NO, I'M NOT GOING TO SIP AND
PUT MY MASK ON.
SIP AND PUT MY MASK ON, SIP AND
PUT MY MASK ON, EAT AND PUT MY
MASK ON.
WHILE I'M EATING AND DRINKING,
I'M GOING TO KEEP MY MASK OFF.
>> OKAY.
WELL, AS THE PANDEMIC OF THE
UNVACCINATED RAGES, A GRIEVING
SON AND DAUGHTER LOSE THEIR
45-YEAR-OLD VACCINE HESITANT DAD
TO COVID AND TELL CNN THEY BLAME
MISINFORMATION FROM TUCKER
CARLSON.
>> YOU SAID FROM ONE MEDIA
SOURCE IN PARTICULAR HE WAS
GETTING MISINFORMATION -- OR
GETTING INFORMATION THAT LED HIM
TO BE HESITANT ON VACCINES.
WHO?
WHO WAS HE LISTENING TO?
>> HE WATCHED SOME TUCKER
CARLSON VIDEOS ON YOUTUBE AND
SOME OF THOSE VIDEOS INVOLVED
SOME MISINFORMATION ABOUT
VACCINES AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT
PLAYED A ROLE.
>> THERE YOU GO.
MISINFORMATION THAT LEADS PEOPLE
TO QUESTION THE VACCINE.
>> IN YOUR MEDICINE, TELL US THE
FULL TRUTH BUT THEY WON'T.
THEY HAVE BEEN TELLING US FOR
SIX MONTHS THAT THIS VACCINE IS
PERFECT BUT CLEARLY, IN SOME
CASES IT DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK.
>> MISINFORMATION THAT MAKES
PEOPLE THINK VACCINATION IS AN
ASSAULT ON THEIR FREEDOM INSTEAD
OF THE LIFE SAVING MEDICAL
MIRACLE IT REALLY IS.
>> IT MAKES YOU THINK ONCE YOU
THINK ABOUT IT THAT MAYBE NONE
OF THIS IS REALLY ABOUT COVID.
MAYBE IT'S ABOUT SOCIAL CONTROL.
>> HE SHOULD KNOW BETTER.
HE SHOULD KNOW BETTER.
THIS IS ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH,
ABOUT SAVING THE LIVES OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
WE HAVE ALL THE VACCINE THAT WE
COULD EVER NEED.
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD WOULD
GIVE ANYTHING TO HAVE THE
VACCINES FAR TOO MANY AMERICA
CAPS ARE TURNING DOWN IN THE
NAME OF AN ILLUSION OF FREEDOM,
AN ILLUSION OF FREEDOM, AN
ILLUSION PUSHED BY PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD KNOW BETTER WHO ACTUALLY
DO KNOW BETTER AND MOST OF THEM
FULLY VACCINATED, THEIR
COMPANIES AND WORK HAVE VACCINE
MANDATES BUT THEY WON'T TELL YOU
THAT.
REMEMBER WHAT SOME AMERICANS
SAID ABOUT THE SEAT BELT
MANDATES BACK TO THE 1980s.
>> I'LL HAVE TO DETOUR THE TOWN
TO GET TO KALAMAZOO.
WHY USE A SEAT BELT?
I WOULD WEAR MY SEAT BELT TO GET
CAUGHT, I GET CAUGHT I GUESS.
>> FLORIDA HIGHWAY PATROL
LIEUTENANT CHRIS MILLER HEARS IT
ALL WHEN IT COMES TO SEAT BELTS.
>> I HEAR IT UNCOMFORTABLE.
IT WRINKLES MY CLOTHES.
IT'S NOT COOL.
>> THERE IS NO FREEDOM NO MORE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO WEAR IT,
THAT'S YOUR CHOICE.
>> SOUND FAMILIAR?
LISTEN, I KNOW WE'RE -- I WANT
YOU TO PLAY THAT.
I WANT YOU GUYS, PLAY IT AGAIN,
PLEASE.
I WANT YOU GUYS WHEN THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT, I WANT YOU
GUYS TO THINK ABOUT VACCINES AND
MASKS AND THEY'RE LIKE IT'S
UNCOMFORTABLE.
IT SHOULDN'T BE A MANDATE, IT'S
MY FREEDOM.
THINK ABOUT THE VACCINE.
JUST LISTEN TO IT AND THEN SUPER
IMPOSE, IF YOU WILL, OVER THAT
MASKS OR VACCINES WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
LET'S PLAY IT ALL AGAIN.
>> I'LL HAVE TO DETOUR THE DOWN
TO GET TO KALAMAZOO IF THEY PASS
A SEAT BELT LAW.
I DON'T USE A SEAT BELT.
>> I WON'T WEAR MY SEAT BELT.
IF I GET CAUGHT, I GET CAUGHT.
>> HIGHWAY PATROL CHRIS MILLER
HEARS IT ALL WHEN SEAT BELTS.
>> I HEAR IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE.
IT WRINKLES MY CLOTHES.
IT'S NOT COOL.
>> THERE IS NO FREEDOM NO MORE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO WEAR IT,
THAT'S YOUR CHOICE.
>> NOW PEOPLE BASICALLY, WHEN
YOU GET IN A CAR ESPECIALLY IN
THE FRONT SEAT YOU ALMOST HAVE
TO PUT YOUR SEAT BELT ON.
SOME CARS GO OVER YOU
AUTOMATICALLY.
OTHERS, NO ONE TALKS ABOUT THAT
ANYMORE.
PEOPLE JUST, GUESS WHAT?
THEY WEAR THEIR SEAT BELTS.
IT'S THE LAW.
NO FREEDOM, NO CHOICE.
THEY SAID IT ABOUT SEAT BELTS.
NOW THEY'RE SAYING IT ABOUT
VACCINES AND MASKS AND WE HAVE
MAJOR NEWS TO TELL YOU ABOUT.
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE CASE OF
GABBYPETITO.
OKAY?
CHRIS GAVE YOU EARLIER ABOUT
WHAT THE FAMILY IS SAYING, THE
FBI SEARCH IS HAPPENING AT THE
FAMILY HOME.
IT HAPPENED TODAY OF HER FIANCEE
BRIAN LAUNDRIE FOR HOURS, JUST
ONE DAY AFTER INVESTIGATORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOUND WHAT
THEY BELIEVE TO BE HER REMAINS.
BUT THERE IS STILL NO SIGN OF
LAUNDRIE WHO CAME BACK TO
FLORIDA IN MONTH AND REFUSED TO
TALK TO INVEST GATORS AND WENT
MISSING LAST WEEK.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO THIS.
THIS IS A CHILLING 911 CALL.
THE CALLER REPORTING WHAT HE
CALLS A DOMESTIC DISPUTE BETWEEN
PETITO AND LAUNDRIE LAST MONTH.
>> WE DROVE BY AND THE GENTLEMEN
WAS STOPPING THE GIRL.
>> HE WAS SLAPPING HER?
>> HE PROCEEDED TO HIT HER,
HOPPED IN THE CAR AND THEY DROVE
OFF.
>> UTAH POLICE DESCRIBED THE
COUPLE AS HAVING AN